marjorie was likely bitten by a tiger
shark
one of the main culprits of shark
attacks on surfers in hawaii
tiger sharks tend to be solitary hunters
they're feeding on large prey items and
they have the
the jaws and the hardware that enable
them to take those
big prey items but they're also not
picky they'll
eat whatever they can
known as the garbage can of the ocean
the tiger shark has the hardware
to chew up anything it finds
even license plates and old tires
so here you have a set of jaws from uh
about a
12 foot tiger shark and you can see you
know the the numbers of teeth
that are here and the size of the teal
you know they're big they're heavily
serrated
even the serrations have serrations on
them as that jaw is moving it's it's
slicing across and these become little
blades like on a
chainsaw and not only do they have lots
of teeth they have lots of
replacement teeth behind so they always
have a full set of teeth
rolling in they encounter soft squishy
humans
easily able to get severely damaged by
such strong powerful jaws
[Music]
on marjory's sunset surf time and
location
worked against her tiger sharks are
nocturnal hunters
and she was surfing in an area inhabited
by sea turtles
so a shark swimming along and toward
dusker at night
you see something vaguely on the surface
it's going to come up and investigate
you're sitting on this board with your
arms off to the side which look like
little flippers
on a shark coming up from below might
mistake
this person on the board for a turtle
that's flapping around and
give you an investigatory bite
[Music]
you